you know we thought it would be fun to
have a visit from the Easter Bunny on
our show do a bit about the Easter Bunny
right we thought that'll be great people
are gonna love that here's the problem
we waited until the last minute okay
that's just us that's how we do things
and it is impossible to get a bunny
costume right now you cannot get you
can't wait this late to rent your bunny
Cobb yeah you can't they are all sold
out so we got the best Easter themed
costume we could find on such short
notice this is the best we could do
ladies and gentlemen please enjoy the
visit from spider-man
dressed as an Easter Bunny
[Applause]
[Music]
just
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks a lot spider-man dress this an
Easter Bunny we did the best we could
and I think we did a pretty good job I
have to tell you I have to tell you all
of Israel is proud of you right now
so tell us what did you think about our
take on Easter Jesus oh thanks for
asking
at first I thought the bit was kind of
slapped together but I actually found
myself quite charmed song was cute and
the costume made for a great visual
while it lacked any reference to me
which costed some points I still score
it 3 out of 5 halo congratulations
anything else
Jesus yeah do you mind if I plug my
resurrection not at all go ahead okay
hey everyone don't forget this weekend
is Easter Sunday break out those bonnets
head to church and get your prayer on
because me is risen present very nice
you